hi my name is john i bet judy's i'm
quite apprehensive actually letting me
speak in front of her podcast but anyway
i'm here to talk about creativity
in just seven minutes and you might be
thinking okay how can we possibly talk
about creativity in seven minutes one of
the things i really hate i hear this a
lot from mathematics teachers is that
i'm not creative i can't come up with
these creative things and this really
annoys me because creativity isn't
something you are you aren't creative
person creativity is something that you
do
okay creativity is a process
and everyone here can be creative can
have creative class can do creative
things
everybody isn't innately creative or
uncreative
and this is what i want to highlight in
my talk
we need to actually work that creativity
muscle actually do the creative things
now it's all well and good for me to
just come up here and say okay do
creative so be creative without actually
me actually giving you something in
order to do that
how
how can i actually do creative i'm going
to give you three things here number one
i'm going to tell you how you can learn
about creativity number two i'm going to
actually give you the real meat of my
presentation i'll come to that in a
minute and number three i'm going to
actually talk about inspiration which is
incredibly important when we talk about
creativity but step one is to actually
learn about creativity
do a pd read a book watch a video
actually learning about creativity is
probably the first step that you need in
order to actually do the whole creative
process in order to do creativity
teach like a part is my favorite
teaching book in the whole world teaches
a lot of things talks about passion
talks about failing in order to succeed
but one thing it talks about is
creativity okay and some of the things
i'm talking about actually comes from
the book it's the one teaching book
outside our merlin goose
okay it is a fantastic book it is
inspiring
um by dave burgess really cool guy
hazard who's home ted
okay a lot of people ted is a great
place to learn about things we've got
absolutely inspirational and amazing
speakers speaking about a whole range of
things actually a playlist there it's
over two hours long full of uh
amazing inspirational people talking
about creativity called creation spark
and i suggest that everyone actually
looks that up and i'll be putting it up
on my twitter account a bit later so you
can actually get there
step two and this is the main thing ask
the right questions in order to do
creativity you need to ask yourself
questions by asking yourself the right
questions you can start doing amazing
creative things or even little creative
things something that adds depth to the
classroom something actually gets the
students engaged something that makes
the students remember your class your
lesson something that they will talk
about years to come
can i incorporate movement to this
lesson maybe i can teach transformations
through dancing
um can i get my class outside for this
lesson maybe i can get my class outside
to measure trees using trigonometry
something i did just a few weeks ago a
lot of fun we made our own clinometers
maybe you can think about other ways you
can actually get your class outside for
the lesson can we create human graphs
charts maps or equations can we actually
get the students actually create the
graphs with the entire bodies with their
arms
what songs of lyrics that relate to this
lesson
if you know seasons of love from rent
525
600 minutes
how many minutes in a year okay perfect
for time and there's so many out there
maybe can i allow my student to create
songs or wraps that demonstrate my
understanding i'm sick of tests
so sick of test everyone who's a teacher
is sick of giving the students tests do
something different in order to
demonstrate the understanding in order
to assess them it doesn't need to be
marked but it gives the students an
outlet can i show my students why this
is important in the real world okay this
is incredibly important how can i do
that maybe i can use percentages to get
the best deal
okay i'm sure a lot of students would
like to know that
what aspect the current pop culture can
i use my lesson
okay maybe i can use memes maybe i can
use memes teach content marvel can get
the students create me a lot of um cool
memes out there it's current pop culture
that i think we will actually all know
can i decorate the walls the ceiling or
the floor
can i make my classroom slightly
different can i put posters of the grass
around maybe i can do something even
more creative what comes up when i ask
myself that question
can i just put a qr code on the board
and see what happens
maybe the qr code will link to an
interesting site maybe you'll link to a
video maybe you'll link to like a whole
series of things that the students can
discover
some sort of mathematical concept from
can i use mine techniques and gestures
to get my points across maybe you can
play master raids who knows what this
is disappointing
um can they send
on a scavenger hunt
um through your content mate i've seen
equations scavenging just fine online an
equation's going to talk where you put
equations
and answers but the different equations
of different answers you put them all
across the classroom or even all across
the school and once a student finds an
answer for that equation they get a new
equation they have to find an answer for
that one and find an answer for that one
and they go across the whole classroom
or the whole school doing a scavenger
hunt cunning is the concept of summer to
use technology in my lesson can i
substitute can i augment can i modify it
or can i even redefine my entire lesson
to use technology okay google stuff it's
a really important concept to all
teaching
you should write down your favorite
questions
questions that you hear questions to
come up with yourself and ask yourself
these questions when you want to be
creative when you want to do creative
okay and again a teacher like a pirate
book actually has over 100 questions you
can ask yourself in order to do the
credit
finally inspiration okay the best way to
do the creative thing is by being
inspired um
pinterest okay
find a pinterest board that has a lot of
cool things a lot of cool math teachers
out there a lot of cool teachers out
there who have pinterest boards with
interesting things maybe you can then
share the things that you find on your
pinterest board twitter seriously
everyone needs to get on twitter there
are so many inspiring teachers there's
nord in this sylvia there's eddie
um people that actually inspire me
with what they actually say on twitter
and there's so many people out there
okay so just everyone gets on twitter at
least followed miss anderson
teach me
okay teach me a great uh little pd and
so inspirational short two minutes seven
minute talks that free the convenient
and fun look up tm sydney so i want you
to actually go out there instead of
being creative i want you to do creative
thank you
i'm drake